hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we are going to watch
from the channel marshal Club who
apparently likes our reactions and David
Gandy loyal patronage Act has requested
a double feature of them anime edition
we're gonna watch these back-to-back
shinobi anime live-action ninja fight
five deadly venoms and anime live-action
kawaii death metal god I am excited
because they're funny and talented and
cool but they never want to actually
collab why guys put me in a short film
I'll get kicked in the face I don't care
really add on oh and we're done we're
filming this god dammit John if you want
to work with people in the future it's
about how you treat them oh you [ __ ]
I'm sorry
Hey
sweet diggity
I
[Music]
whoa
gosh hey this is like a fluff galore
fight Wow
oh wow see I could've been this guy yes
hah whoo not bad nope
Oh
ha
[Music]
Wow Wow
whoo-hoo love it huh shinobi obi-wan
Chenault
ah
oh damn real contact this is a real
anime song
yes
these guys why don't these guys had a
million followers yet no you know our
slack and go subscribe okay
never seen Naruto happy edison's - Andy
mm-hmm I did recognize the headband
[Music]
no that's crazy
show me some similarities but lets me
know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no no learn the book books suck kill the
woman first man killer oh snap it's mean
[Music]
just bought a guy who kill them gun club
Oh
[Music]
Oh
whoa ha there we go hell yeah baby
metals
[Music]
it's official
ha
[Music]
hello awesome
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
damn
so different people directing [ __ ] you
got it directly
[Music]
[Music]
what if Andy got so into character in
the moment and really thought he was
being insulted that he broke character
so I kicking all her ass today sending
people the hospital I didn't realize
that they like will switch up their
directors and let people are taking
being able to help us with a specific
project or what not really is a club and
really Zack elect really is a Marshall
Club of all these kinds of artists
they're so great at capturing spirit of
different kinds of Annamayya mylord
really hope that when they finally start
nailing down some anime live-action
adaptations that they're able to direct
or at least choreograph the fights for
them or whatnot because they got the
style down to what t it is amazing what
they can do you've seen such a wide
variety of fight scenes from these guys
it's like yeah the consistency thing
with them is or hyper editing and the
kinetic energy they bring but they're
clearly anime influence as well beyond
Jackie Chan influence or whatever the
way they cut these things together every
little moment just feels like you're
watching a real adaptation I guess but
what I love about them is they let their
fan appreciation they wear it on their
shoulders and then they do their own
thing as well so yeah splice it both
yeah right well I also love the little
accents they're able to get especially
in the second
because you know we've been watching a
lot more anime recently and just the
lines and little pops and things that
they're able to add to punches or add to
certain shots to communicate that extra
level of intensity that you often get
with the harsh shading and lines and
stuff I thought was really cool and I
liked the contrast between these two
because the first one is so badass and
hard-hitting and then the second one is
still badass but really silly in a way
yeah and you know I I just love that you
took the time to do kawaii metal of all
the things because I remember when
babymetal first came on the scene and
that was I'm just so happy right now
well I feel like they're truly rising in
the ranks of being people who will be
self-made in the sense of they're gonna
be in movies they're gonna be directing
their own films are gonna be
choreographing at least a couple of them
I imagine will be starring in a few and
it all started with this one YouTube
channel marshal Club and they're just
gonna keep rising through the ranks in
the ladder and then 10120 they're
actually in movies you just know they're
headed down oh yeah oh yeah and we're
gonna see them in some big stuff one day
because beyond being these great martial
arts and great directors the great
performers - they're funny they really
know how to act so they're gonna be
stars at least one of them has to be a
star one that M has to be a female know
they're gonna have an appearance in the
force awakens that'd be great
yeah this is amazing this is amazing and
consistently entertaining I've watched
plenty of their videos without having to
react to them as well and they react
that's what I want yeah they're an
addicting channel thank you guys so much
for being here please subscribe to
marshal club they need to hit a million
as soon as Paul Chris mistake yeah if
it's not then you were slacking vision
feeling so started misses you can their
channel link is in the description box
into the pin comment subscribe to the
reel rejects please click that
notification bell get notified when we
got our video up David Gandy I have to
apologize man did not expect so many big
things to be coming out because it's
like we film for YouTube and patreon and
all the editing might not seem like a
lot to some people but trust me it is
you were out visiting in our area in
California recently couldn't meet
I'm sorry I really wanted to see her
[ __ ] in new BOTS as you started working
out or doing martial arts I can just
imagine how its sex she looked in person
and truth be told I didn't meet up with
you because I was afraid that I would
end up leaving my girlfriend to pursue a
relationship with you and I'm sorry
you think you could train me in the next
time you're in town I need to get my my
body rocking so that I can you know join
you in a martial clothes video
specifically his ass my ass I don't have
one he's got a flat butt yeah and David
huge AB can you help me get that bubble
butt that onion booty I don't remember
what do his face looks like but is that
dead a damn Jay resigner house